por ahora no habrá reforma policial en
eeuu tras meses de conversaciones los
demócratas anunciaron que no llegaron a
un acuerdo con los republicanos la gran
reforma buscaba acabar con los abusos
por parte de la policía especialmente
contra la minoría afroamericana
el comienzo tras la muerte de georg
floyd el 25 de mayo de 2020 que murió
asfixiado a manos de un policía mientras
decía las palabras no puedo respirar la
muerte de floyd causó una ola de
protestas en ciudades como minneapolis
nueva york y washington luego vinieron
otras muertes de afroamericanos también
a manos de la policía lo que encendió
aún más la protesta y la indignación el
presidente de estadounidense joe biden
culpó a los republicanos del fin de las
negociaciones
lamentablemente los republicanos del
senador rechazaron la promulgación de
reformas modestas que incluso el
presidente anterior había apoyado al
tiempo que se negaron a tomar medidas
sobre cuestiones clave que muchos en las
fuerzas del orden estaban dispuestos a
tratar el acuerdo estaba empantanado en
un punto clave la inmunidad legal para
la policía que hace muy difícil
interponer demandas contra los agentes
que estén acusados de haber usado la
fuerza de manera desproporcionada bailén
buscará ahora otros caminos con
defensores de derechos civiles y con
familiares de las víctimas para cumplir
con el ideal de igualdad ante la
justicia el mandatario quería aprobarla
antes del primer aniversario de la
muerte de floyd pero las diferencias en
el congreso se lo impidieron